6 25 on your wednesday morning we have
now on the other side of waiting at a
green light remember that email from the
other day viewer stephen was wondering
why cars don't just go already when a
traffic light turns green i suggested
those drivers are probably on their
phones well thank you for some pretty
quick responses the chair now recognizes
steve who writes hey people sitting
behind a car that doesn't go on green
don't know what the car in front of them
sees the pedestrian wheelchair or
bicycle going against the light or all
the cars running the red light i've seen
or avoided many a collision by being
cautious patient
and ignoring quick draw horn honkers
thank you steve the chair now recognizes
tiffany says pretty much the same thing
as steve but she adds maybe we can
address all the crashes from drivers who
don't stop at red lights you got that
tiffany now uh ron he writes when you
come to a stoplight and the light turns
green you have to wait because there's
always a late person flying across the
opposite direction i don't want to be
t-boned we got time for one more here's
kathleen she writes at a red light at
fort apache and say here a guy came past
me on my right going through the red
light at 60 65 miles an hour if the
people with the green light had pulled
right out that would have been a
horrible crash she says i for one always
hesitate look both ways before i move on
not everyone is on their phone
thanks kathleen ron tiffany and steve
for writing in buckle up drive carefully
and please put down that phone if there
is something driving you crazy email me
traffic 8 8newsnow.com